guten tag meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren ich begrüße sie heute zu unserer
pressekonferenz nachdem die
französischen behörden die informationen
mitgeteilt haben
ich begrüße hier bei mir kapitän zeit
von der germanwings thomas winkelmann
den cod germanwings und carsten spohr
den vorstandsvorsitzenden der lufthansa
vor sie haben das wort ja meine damen
und herren nach der auswertung des voice
recorders unseres strategischen fluges
eines zuges germanwings 95 25 hat sich
eine neue sehr tragische wendung ergeben
wir müssen nun ich glaube ich für alle
über lufthansa fassungslos zur kenntnis
nehmen dass das flugzeug offensichtlich
will ich zum absturz gebracht wurde
mutmaßlich durch den co piloten des
fluges die aufnahmen des voice recorders
legen nahe dass der kapitän nach
erreichen des reise fluges das cockpit
für kurze zeit verlassen hat und
anschließend leider nicht mehr
zurückkehren konnte es scheint sich zu
bewahrheiten dass der im cockpit
verbliebene kollege der co-pilot ihm den
zutritt zum cockpit nicht wieder
ermöglicht hat um den tödlichen sinkflug
in die französischen alpen hinein
einzuleiten
darin sahen es macht uns fassungslos
hierbei lufthansa hier bei germanwings
ich kann also noch mal wiederholen was
ich die letzten tage sagt er will sind
betroffen und erschüttert und ich hätte
mir nicht vorstellen können dass ich das
noch mal verstärkt mit dem was heute so
meiner kenntnis gebracht wurde hat es
sich aber doch mal verstärkt wenn es
sowas überhaupt geben kann
ich glaube auch hier nicht nur für mich
zu sprechen bieten in seinen schlimmsten
albträumen da hätten wir uns nicht
vorstellen können dass sich solch eine
tragödie bei uns im konzern einen kann
diejenigen die uns in der branche
beobachten und kennen wissen dass wir
cockpitpersonal sehr sehr sorgfältig
auswählen
wir machen das auch deswegen weil es zu
unserem selbstverständnis gehört war das
teil unserer dna ist das woran wir
glauben bei lufthansa und wir
untersuchen bei der auswahl unserer
kandidaten nicht nur kognitive und
technische fähigkeiten sondern gerade
auch in den ausläufer fahren lassen wir
viel raum für die psychologische eignung
der kandidaten wir arbeiten dort
zusammen mit der deutschen gesellschaft
für luft- und raumfahrtforschung seit
vielen vielen jahrzehnten
und dieser sogar dglr test deutsche
luftfahrt deutsche zentrum für luft und
raumfahrt der er das ist glaube ich
weltweit es da nicht sagen anerkanntes
instrument zur rekrutierung
qualifizierter cockpitbesatzung und ist
vielleicht weltweit sogar das führende
verfahren dafür
und wir sind sehr stolz darauf und dass
das was war passiert ist war einfach
nicht für uns vorstellbar
beide piloten haben diesen test
natürlich durchlaufen und danach an der
flugschule in bremen und dann in phoenix
arizona ihre ausbildung durchlaufen
der co pilot hat seine ausbildung im
jahr 2008 begonnen hatte nach der
ausbildung eine elfmonatige wartezeit
das ist bei uns nicht unüblich in dieser
zeit hat er bei uns als flugbegleiter
zunächst gearbeitet um die wartezeit zu
überbrücken und war dann seid 2013 bei
uns als co-pilot der offizielle name ist
als erster offizier auf dem airbus 320
auf diesem flugzeugmuster tätig es gab
das möchte ich erwähnen vor sechs jahren
in der ausbildung eine längere
unterbrechung
nachdem die eignung des kandidaten dann
noch mal festgestellt wurde hat er die
ausbildung wieder aufgenommen er hat
wieder folge nicht nur alle
medizinischen tests bestanden sondern
auch alle fliegerischen schulungen alle
pflegerischen prüfungen und 6 gestanden
100% flugtauglich ohne jegliche
einschränkungen ohne jegliche auflagen
die fliegerische leistung waren
einwandfrei ohne jede auffälligkeit den
namen unternehmen mit dem unseren wo wir
so stolz darauf sind und so viel wert
auf qualität sicherheit gute ausfall
legen das können sie mir glauben ist das
natürlich ein vielleicht noch besonders
schwerer schock als ich über so für uns
alle glaube ich ein schock ist und für
die öffentlichkeit
ein schock ist wir können heute wenige
stunden nach der erkenntnis über motive
glaube ich erst mal nur spekulieren
wir haben keinerlei erkenntnisse was die
co piloten zu dieser schrecklichen
handlungen veranlasst haben könnte
und ich möchte auch an der stelle ganz
bewusst noch mal sagen
das auch nach diesem mit abstand
furchtbar ist ein ereignis dieser ganzen
geschichte unseres konzerns der 60 jahre
alt wird nicht nur ich sondern auch
meine kollegen absolutes um volles
vertrauen in unsere piloten haben sie
sind und das habe ich auch anderer
stelle gesagt einer auch nicht einfache
situation sie sind und bleiben die
besten der welt
das ist das was wir bei lufthansa seit
jahrzehnten zum teil dieser die ek
gemacht haben
wir sind ganz ganz fester bestandteil
unserer marke und für mich ist das was
hier passiert ist einfach nur
unglaublich tragischer einzelfall
und das ist mir durchaus wichtig auch
hier zu betonen und wir alle stehen
gemeinsam mit den hinterbliebenen den
angehörigen und den familien und
freunden der opfer und wahrscheinlich
übertreibe ich nicht mit millionen von
menschen einfach nur von riesigen rätsel
und wir sind traurig dabei und es wird
zeit auch auf dauer glaube ich bis wir
das alles richtig verstehen was hier
passiert ist
wir sind aber auch profis und deswegen
werden wir natürlich alles tun bei der
aufklärung bestmöglich zu unterstützen
unsere leute sind vor ort in
südfrankreich hatte ich ihnen schon vor
zwei tagen gesagt natürlich bleibt das
jetzt auch im fokus ich möchte auch mal
feststellen egal welche
sicherheitsvorkehrungen sieht ein
unternehmen haben egal wie hoch sie
sicherheit hin und wir haben in dem
bereich wirklich hohe standards ein
solches einzelnes ereignis lässt sich
nicht komplett ausschließen
kein system der welt kann ein solches
einzelne eigenes glauben tauschen
essen und erlaubt so eine persönliche
bemerkung zum schluss bei lufthansa als
ingenieur gearbeitet ich habe bei
lufthansa als pilot gearbeitet ich trag
der lufthansa hat viel vielen jahren
verantwortung als führungskraft immer
egal wo ich war
egal wie mein chef war halt immer die
regel safety ist nummer eins und dass
das gerade uns passiert das tut uns
einfach nur leid
vielen dank das machen da hab ich ja
wenn es üblich wäre ihnen dankbar wenn
sie ihre fragen laut stellen würden
damit ihre kollegen sie auch hören
können
ganz hinten an betreibt es gibt keine
möglichkeit einen unfall zu vermeiden
gibt es nicht eine möglichkeit zu denen
er kommandeur kommandanten wenn kapitän
wieder in die kabine reinzukommen mich
an geheimcode ebenso schrecklichen
ereignissen des 11 septembers verfahren
und trocken geändert glauben sie dass
sie mir kurz darauf eingehe
bei weiteren fragen an unterstützung auf
dem podium meiner eigenen erfahrung sind
ja schon ein paar jahre alt als und
verkoppelt die türen sind nach dem 11
september gepanzert worden um
grundsätzlich ein zugriff tritt zum
cockpit wegen der wunsch der
cockpitbesatzung nicht möglich zu machen
gepanzert worden sogar so dass er mit
kleinkalibrigen waffen auch mit
waffengewalt nicht geöffnet werden kann
wenn einer unserer piloten oder
grundsätzlich in der luftfahrt als
cockpit verlässt zum beispiel aus
biologischen gründen kann er an der tür
klingeln
wer im cockpit befindliche kollege hat
bildschirme mehrere um zu schauen wer
derjenige ist der vor der tür steht und
einlass gewährt wenn es der kollege ist
oder natürlich ein andere kolleginnen
oder kollegen aus der kabinencrew gibt
es einen knopf mit dem diese elektrisch
gesicherte tür aufspringt die behörden
und die ausrüster und wir haben auch
vorkehrungen für den fall getroffen dass
in diesem moment wo einer der pilot das
cockpit verlassen hat der andere pilot
zum beispiel bewusstlos wird
dafür gibt es einen weiteren code einer
erweiterten code den man dann an der tür
angeben kann
der auch zu einem klingelzeichen führt
und wenn dann auch dieses klingelzeichen
nicht geantwortet wird geht die tür
elektrisch auf und erlaubt den zugang
dieses öffnen kann
von dem im cockpit befindlichen kollegen
verhindert werden indem er während des
klingelns ein schalter outlook
geschlossen legt dann ist die korrektur
für fünf minuten verriegelt wir können
und wollen jetzt hier nicht über die
erkenntnisse der französischen behörde
hinaus spekulieren
es muss entweder so gewesen sein dass
der kapitän beim versuch ins cockpit zu
kommen diesen erweiterten code nicht
eingegeben hat was wir uns alle nicht
erklären können in diesem code kennt
jeder von uns rund um die uhr auswendig
und das wäre das übliche verfahren oder
aber der kollege hat diesen code
eingegeben und der im cockpit
befindliche kollege hat durch blockieren
des schalters dadurch umstellt des
schalters auf block aufgeschlossen
verhindert dass die tür elektrisch
auflädt
mehr dazu wissen wir heute noch nicht
wissen daten auf die ausbildung müssen
ergänzt zu dieser frage nein das war das
war korrekt
google habe nie gesagt dass der co pilot
die ausbildungen vor sechs jahren
unterbrochen hat mich würde
interessieren wie lange er diese
ausbildung unterbrochen hat und warum es
war eine mehrmonatige unterbrechung der
ausbildung auch das ist nicht völlig
unmöglich bei uns und zu den gründen der
unterbrechung darf ich leider keine
auskunft geben
aber ich habe ja gesagt jemand der bei
uns eine ausbildung unterbricht muss
danach wieder die eignung für die
fortsetzung der ausbildung nachweisen
auch die medizinische eignung wird
nachgewiesen so gesehen ist für uns
relevanten nach jeder unterbrechung bin
immer wieder anfängt hat er die eignung
für die fortsetzung der ausbildung das
auch jeder fall gewesen
vielfalt das ist ein medizinischen grund
gegeben hätte für die unterbrechung gilt
in deutschland die medizin
schweigepflicht auch über den tod hinaus
und die gilt nicht nur von mir gegenüber
der öffentlichkeit die gilt sogar
gegenüber hier als vorstandsvorsitzenden
des unternehmens
das wird teil der status der
staatsanwaltschaft die untersuchungen
seien dann auch entsprechende unterlagen
einzusehen das dürfen wir als
unternehmen nicht und kann und könnte es
deswegen auch gar nicht weitergeben was
gibt's denn matthias simmerer reuters
gibt es denn nach beendigung der
ausbildung für tätige piloten auf
psychologischen chats oder gespräche
dass man in anführungszeichen dass alles
in ordnung ist mit den kollegen
es gibt natürlich bei uns regelmäßige
fliegerischen überprüfungen und es gibt
auch einmal ja eine medizinische
untersuchung explizite psychologische
text test oder untersuchung gibt es
nicht mehr
wohl aber natürlich in der ausbildung
unserer piloten auf führungsfähigkeiten
achten jeder erster offizier ist so
ausgebildet bei lufthansa dass er auch
bei einer sogenannten capacity des
kapitäns also falls der kapitän die
flugfähig ist das flugzeug als
stellvertretender kommandant dann als
kommandant führen kann
und teil dieser ausbildung unser co
piloten die durchgeführt wird ist
natürlich auch die psychologische sagen
wir vorbereitet auf diese
führungsaufgabe aber einen expliziten
test
hier ist versucht verbundes abend und
von europäischen behörden nicht
vorgesehen und gibt es auch nicht die
kolleginnen in den blauen pullover in
der letzten reihe kämpfen von rudow
nachrichtensender aus nord irak und
meine frage ist ich war heute am haltern
am see
da trauen die menschen 16 schüler und
zwei lehrerinnen und das ist sehr
traurig der zweite sagte uns die haben
angst demnächst zu fliegen
hässliches sicherheit gibt es jetzt
überhaupt wie können sie diese angst
nehmen
fliegen ist die sicherste art setzt des
transportes ist mit den letzten jahren
auch immer noch sicherer geworden
auch hierüber lufthansa haben ein in der
branche nur von wenigen airlines
erreichen
save the record mit hunderttausenden von
flügen jedes jahr
deswegen kann ich jedem nur sagen
genauso wie lufthansa bisher ein völlig
stringenten fokus auf dem thema
flugsicherheit hat haben wir die noch
weiter hin
und vielleicht sind die gefühle ein
bisschen andere geworden aber der
professionelle fokus auf dem thema ist
ungebrochen und bleibt der lufthansa hat
diese seite
computop ski vom wdr sie haben gesagt
dass also voraussichtlich der co-pilot
den absturz vorsätzlich herbeigeführt
hat da kann es ja unterschiedliche
motive geben die müssen ja nicht
unbedingt im persönlichen begründet sein
gibt es irgendwelche anhaltspunkte oder
möchten sie die zumindest nicht
ausschließen dass womöglich noch ein
terroranschlag eine rolle gespielt haben
könnte ich kann mich da nur unserem
herrn bundesinnenminister anschließen
der vor einer stunde ab oder feste waren
hier gibt es keinerlei anzeichen
sowohl aus sicht des bundesministeriums
und der nachrichtendienste und auch wir
als arbeitgeber des jungen kern haben
dafür keine anzeichen
gestatten sie mir bitte noch eine zweite
frage der pilot hat das cockpit
verlassen gibt es eine routine bei
germanwings lufthansa das für den cyber
der abwesenheit von einem cockpit
mitglied einen andere personen des
personals für den zeitpunkt ins cockpit
kommt und wenn ja warum war das wohl
nicht der fall
nein dieses prozedere gibt es nicht nur
bei lufthansa nicht das ist in europa in
deutschland nicht vorgesehen es gibt
weltweit wenige airlines die ein solches
prozedere haben aber wie fast alle
unserer großen wettbewerber und in
europa noch ich werde mir kein einziger
alten haben will das nicht können sie
uns etwas genaueres sagen über ihre
psychologische untersuchung der piloten
aber auch ihres biografischen
hintergrundes ist umfeldes der familien
für unsere bewerber dem auch ein
psychologisches auswahlverfahren als
teil liegt danach mit der kunden
natürlich kontinuierlich beobachtet in
seiner ausbildungsphase und dann später
auch von seinen ausbilder im flugzeug
aber das von ihnen angesprochen darüber
hinausgehende interviewen von freunden
und
familien glaube ich gibt es auf der
ganzen welt nicht nur bei uns natürlich
auch nicht
bitte sie hinten nur in der letzten
reihe ganz aus new york times
können sie uns sagen welchen flugschein
er genau hatte er hatte er wohl einen
flugschein auch für den transport von
passagieren wie viele flugstunden hat
können sie uns so etwas mehr sagen
zweite frage war es dem piloten denn
auch gestattet dem kommandanten das
cockpit zu verlassen zu dem zeitpunkt
des fluges natürlich und das gilt auch
für unsere tochtergesellschaften wir
unter anderem germanwings ein prozedere
das dem einzelnen beiden piloten das
verlassen des cockpits für kurze zeit
erlaubt letztendlich aus biologischen
gründen und der kapitän der das cockpit
im reiseflug auf 38.000 fuß verlassen
hat hat es genauso gemacht wie wir das
produkt an den schulen
wir versuchen dann das cockpit des
verlassen werden muss zu verlassen wenn
die arbeitsbelastung am geringsten ist
für die beiden ko member und das ist im
reiseflug der fall
in dem fall kann der kollege also
vorbildlich gehandelt er hat gewartet
ist das 15.000 30.000 fuß war und dann
das cockpit verlassen und der kopilot
der first officer wenn ich ihre frage
richtig verstanden habe war natürlich im
besitz einer gültigen verkehrspiloten
lizenz als erster offizier für das
flugzeug das rating besaß den airbus
a320
wenn das nicht ihre farbe diese norm
hinterher zu gehen
die fragen verstanden die
tarifkommission mit weniger basteln
irgend eine unterhaltung zwischen dem co
piloten und dem piloten bevor der pilot
wds lkw denn das cockpit verlassen hat
was heute der französische staatsanwalt
gesagt habe es gab ein technisches
briefing über den weiteren flugverlauf
und dann hat offensichtlich der kapitän
vor bedrohten das steuer überlassen da
gibt es bei uns in der flur einen festen
begriff für josef control was nichts
anderes heißt hat jetzt die flugzeug
kontrolle des füllstandes cockpit an
verlassen sonst ist von uns vom
staatsanwalt und den tonaufnahmen die
dort vorgestellt wurden vor zwei stunden
keine andere konversation benannt
bekannt der kräuter mediengruppe hatte
ich gehe ich nehme ihren äußerungen dass
sie schon fast fest davon ausgehen dass
der co pilot ein selbstmord begangen hat
was macht sie da so sicher ist es
komplett auszuschließen dass der pilot
sich vielleicht auch in der aufregung
bei der eingabe siebenstelligen notfall
kurz vielleicht auch vertan hat oder
haben sie konkrete anhaltspunkte dafür
dass es sich tatsächlich um 149 fachen
mord und suizid handelt dazu kann ich
nicht mehr sagen als der französische
staatsanwalt heute bekannt gegeben hat
wir müssen wie ich ihnen gerne
geschildert habe davon ausgehen dass das
flugzeug bildlich in den boden geflogen
wurde alles weitere werden die weiteren
untersuchungen zeigen
ganz hinten in der letzten reihe hätte
michael geholfen kölner stadt anzeiger
welche seelsorgerischen angebote werden
piloten von germanwings denn gemacht
falls es mal zu psychologischen
problemen kommt während der dienstzeit
was also alle unsere kurs piloten sowie
auch flugbegleiter bekommen von einem
sogenannten diesem team mit geschulten
psychologen an jeder station hilfe wenn
sie diese hilfe möchten
die frage bei ihm hatte ich schon länger
zeiten des co piloten wäre die erste
frage und wenn es doch schon
auffälligkeit während der ausbildung gab
wie kann es sein dass solch ein pilot
dann doch noch die zulassung bekommt ja
wir sind keine anderen unterbrechungen
der flugtauglichkeit als dies bekannt
kollege bestätigt dass noch mal wenn
immer es zur ausbildung rechnung kommt
stellen wir die eignung für die
fortsetzung der ausbildung fest was
immer der grund für die unterbrechung
war wird dann als zeugnis wieder geprüft
wer kann ich dazu wie gesagt heute nicht
sagen da habe ich dazu nicht sagen
und wenn die eigenen wieder hergestellt
ist jetzt natürlich unsere jungen
kollegen ihre ausbildung fort wie andere
ausbildung auch und das war wie gesagt
hätte wie vor sechs jahren in diesem
fall vor gefallen
welche konsequenzen hat die hat der
vorfall denn jetzt für die auswahl für
die ausbildung und das screening von
piloten anwärtern und piloten
lassen sie mich vielleicht noch mal kurz
das wiederholen was ich in einem
eingangsworten gesagt habe trotz dieses
entspreche hoffentlich für alle hier
brauche dieses fürchterliche
einzelfalles dieser tragödie habe ich
und meine kollegen im vorstand und der
geschäftsführung der germanwings wir
alle festes vertrauen in dieses
jahrzehntelang erprobte auswahlverfahren
und auch ausbildungs verfahren das sich
da anschließt wir glauben lufthansa
gerade dass diese homogene
pilotenausbildung für große flugbetriebe
mit unseren ein ganz ganz wichtiges
sicherheitsmerkmal darstellt er lässt
mich jetzt um dieser einen einzelfall
sicher ist auch nicht daran zweifeln wir
werden trotzdem natürlich uns mit den
experten im hause
mit zehn experten bei der deutschen
gesellschaft für luft und raumfahrt
sicherlich auch mit den experten im
bundesverkehrsministerium und ich hatte
auch schon kurz kontakt hatte mit herrn
schulz dem präsidenten der vereinigung
cockpit mit denen wir an dieser stelle
auch sehr kooperativ zusammenarbeiten
wir werden uns hinsetzen natürlich
überlegen was können wir noch besser
machen
bei der auswahl was können wir noch
besser machen bei der ausbildung aber
das ist nicht zu verwechseln mit meinem
grundsätzlichen vertrauen in das was die
lufthansa zehnten durchführt und mehr
als 10.000 piloten hervorragend
ausgewählt und ausgebildet hat die
kollegin bei der kamera da vorne
passagieren auf den hin auf dem hinflug
von auffälligkeiten aufgefallen sind
wenn es um den copiloten geht können sie
was dazu sagen nein kann ich nicht also
mir persönlich ist es nicht bekannt und
schließt auch nicht bekannt dass im
hause dazu informationen gibt wir machen
wir müssen wir nachgehen nach dieser
veranstaltung
danke gibt es weitere fragen ja bitte
sehr
damit verschärfen dpa wie gestalten sich
jetzt die haftungsfragen nach diesen
neuigkeiten wer kommt für das unglück
jetzt auf es ist bekannt dass wir gerade
gestern ich war in düsseldorf und in
barcelona waren angehörige jetzt erstmal
finanzielle soforthilfe zugesichert habe
um auch gerade menschen die finanzielle
engpässe haben jetzt schnell zu
ermöglichen dass wir dort zu
unterstützen können wie es nur irgendwie
geht
und sonst gibt es natürlich für uns als
luftverkehrsgesellschaft diverse
internationale abkommen in den haftungen
geregelt sind und diese halten wir uns
und ich danke ganz ehrlich sagen dass es
auch heute allemal geringsten sorgen
der lufthansa konzern ist verziehen
stabil genug um all diesen ansprüchen
nachzukommen und wir helfen einfach
jetzt erstmal buchen können wir möchten
wir nicht öffentlich nennen aber sie ist
ausreichend um unabhängig von der
finanziellen situation über die nächsten
schwierige wochen und monate zu kommen
ich glaube hier wäre jetzt auch alles
andere fehl am platze mir hierzu
kleingeistig
einen angehörigen kennen diese summe und
wir sind gerade dabei die formalitäten
umzusetzen
der ariane müde vom zdf eine frage sind
piloten andy verpflichtet
auffälligkeiten bei kollegen zu melden
wenn man bei denen probleme feststellen
also sie sind zumindest immer
verpflichtet wenn irgendwelche
besonderheiten sind da gibt es mehrere
regeln die das auch bei uns genau
beschreiben
und wenn solche sachen geschehen dann
sind ja auch verpflichtet
so war es an uns zu reporten ob das denn
jedes mal einzeln für eine person gültig
ist kann man im detail nicht sagen aber
generell gibt es immer eine eine
meldepflicht bei uns flucht
besonderheiten
besondere vorkommnisse da gibt es ganz
ganz viele gesetzlich geregelte
meldepflichten die dame mit der news and
trading will ich jetzt noch mal
nachfragen die frage schon beantwortet
haben
es gibt auch eine internationale regeln
dass wenn der pilot das cockpit verletzt
dass ein anderer mit rein muss in den
vereinigten staaten von amerika ist das
so wenn ein pilot dies cockpit seien am
lässt muss ein anderes co mitglied in
das shop mit bei uns in deutschland ist
das nicht bei keiner der großen airlines
werden sie das in zukunft so einführen
sehe dass die notwendigkeit dass es sich
hier um einen einzelfall wird es auf
jeden fall mit den entsprechenden
experten
lufthansa konzern mit unseren
verschiedenen airlines über deutschen
bundesregierung darüber sprechen ob wir
etwas ändern müssen wir werden aber auf
gar keinen fall jetzt kurzfristig und
hast dich irgendwelche entscheidung
nicht verhindert sie haben also volles
vertrauen
das habe ich schon zweimal gesagt
geschichte wiederhole das gerne noch
einmal englisch
wir haben bei der ausbildung bei der
auswahl der ausbildung der
qualifizierung und in die arbeit unserer
piloten
dies hat sich nicht geändert durch
diesen einzelfall diese tragödien
vielleicht auf englisch noch einmal
erörtern erklärt der innen milch die
wahrscheinlichkeit eines terroristischen
hintergrund es für ausgeschlossen hat
germanwings und die lufthansa es handelt
sich hier unter umständen um einen
suizid
als vorteil des großen unternehmen das
würde ich sagen wenn ein mensch 149
andere mittel wenn tod nimmt ist das für
mich ein anderes wort als selbstmord
sportlich befindet sich im moment auch
im umbau des konzerns auch die
germanwings spielt eine entscheidende
rolle soll ab herbst euro was im
wesentlichen heißen jetzt ist die
situation so traumatisierend auch für
ihre piloten viele sind moment nicht mit
zum pflegen sie müssen das vertrauen der
passagiere auch wieder gewinnen könnte
das bedeuten dass sie ihre pläne
eventuell aufschieben müssen das erst
wieder ruhe und vertrauen zurückgekehrt
ist bei den passagieren in der
mannschaft hat das einflüsse ich glaube
nicht dass heute der richtige tag ist um
über zukünftige strategien der lufthansa
zu diskutieren jetzt gilt es erstmal wie
es auch letzten zwei tage gesagt habe
den angehörigen jegliche unterstützung
zukommen zu lassen
gerade mit den jüngsten erkenntnissen
von heute glaube ich gilt es auch
erstmal dass wir alle gemeinsam praktika
sogar die öffentlichkeit mit
einschließen damit klarkommen was hier
passiert ist und dann zu gegebener zeit
darüber nachdenken welche strategischen
planungen die lufthansa umsetzt was die
zukunft angeht
was ist können sie ihre entscheidung
noch beeinflussen das werden da wollen
sie jetzt noch mal nachdenken da ich
habe ja gesagt darf so gibt es dort
keinen anlass zu spekulieren und zu
diskutieren wo ich ja bild zeitung heute
morgen haben sie eine vollbesetzte
maschine
köln bonner flughafen zurückbeordert in
tel aviv gestartet war
welche gründe dahinter kann ich ihnen
jetzt aktuell gar nicht länder
überrascht und drei stunden deshalb also
wenn eine maschine zurück kommt dann hat
es ganz sicher gründe gute gründe dafür
gegeben
und wahrscheinlich sind aufgrund ihrer
kapitän dann in dem moment so
entschieden hat
aus dem modellflug dann gar nicht erst
anzutreten
die genauen gründe kann ich aktuell
leider nicht im tor hast du aber
ungelöst ich würde folgendes vorschlagen
dem von uns hier keiner die antwort
kennt wird er schützt sie nach der
pressekonferenz anrufen in genau sagen
worum es geht
jetzt könnte ja sein dass ihr
irgendwelche erkenntnisse hat zudem
personal zurück gar nicht schlachten
dass flugzeuge halb flugzeug ist
unterwegs macht ellery und beliefern den
grund verzögerung als sie erfahren haben
was der mögliche grund sein könnte für
den abschluss haben sie da sofort die
angehörigen informiert und haben sie das
persönlich gesagt oder die haben die
angehörten davon erfahren wie angehörige
befinden sich seit dem unfall vor zwei
tagen bei unsere betreuung ein teil der
angehörigen ist auf dem weg nach
marseille gewesen
ein anderer teil ist europa anderen
orten und wir haben gemeinsam mit
behörden dafür sorge tragen können dass
sie angehörige ist nicht über die medien
erfahren haben weiterfahren
horst reiser werde ich habe eine kleine
frage zuvor weg hat die kabinenbesatzung
unabhängig vom cockpit in einer
situation wo sie erkennt da ist
irgendwas nicht in ordnung die
möglichkeit so etwas wie einen notruf
abzusetzen und die zweite frage sie sind
in den vergangenen tagen mit sehr vielen
theorien und spekulationen konfrontiert
gewesen beispielsweise altes flugzeug
billig-airline vielleicht nicht so gute
ausbildung bei germanwings wie bei der
lufthansa oder auch das argument zapf
luft sind die piloten ohnmächtig gewesen
im lichte der neuen entwicklungen wie
sehen sie diese spekulationen die sie
gehört hatten
zur ersten frage auch unsere kabinen
kurs kennen diesen code mit dem der
zugang zum cockpit möglich ist ohne
öffnung des cockpits von innen das nach
dem was wir wissen kann mir nicht zur
anwendung ich hab's erwähnt aber das ist
das was die kabinen kurs auch machen
können darüber hinaus erhalten die
campus keine schulung im cockpit selbst
das erlaubt der gesetzgeber auch nicht
mehr beschränkt dies aufkommen voll
lizenzierte piloten notruf müsste im
cockpit ausgelöst werden dazu müsste man
eine lizenz haben im cockpit aktiv sein
zu können das erlaubt der gesetzgeber
nur für komplett lizenzierten piloten
ich habe zu diesem jungen die sie gerade
angesprochen haben die stellung genommen
ich habe immer gesagt die lufthansa
bildet ihre germanwings piloten genauso
aus wie ihre lufthansa piloten wird
technik betreut die germanwings
flugzeuge sowie die lufthansa flugzeuge
und auch die flugzeuge sind
unterschiedlichen alters wobei er war
ein alter war ein verkehrsflugzeug wird
es richtig gewartet wird keine rolle
spielt für diese richtige wertung sorgen
die kollegen der lufthansa technik und
die
zufälligkeit es ist das flugzeug jetzt
etwas älter war hat nichts für
germanwings zu tun wir haben wir
übrigens sehr junge flugzeuge war auch
bei lufthansa etwas älter ich danke
ihnen herzlich meine damen und herren es
gibt noch eine weitere frage dann noch
beenden
sie haben ja heute auch schon gesehen
dass der name von dem kopiloten und auch
das soziale profil ist dass der mann der
auf dem bild auf facebook vor der golden
gate bridge zu sehen ist
die untersuchungsbehörden in frankreich
die dort zusammen mit der deutschen
untersuchungsbehörde arbeiten überlassen
aber eine frage dann bitte ich dabei
herzlich um verständnis dass wir dann
zum ende kommen
sie haben gerstenberg vom stern sie
haben eben gesagt dass die angehörigen
persönlich informiert haben wir haben
die dann reagiert nachdem die jetzt sich
mit der situation auseinandersetzen
müssen dass es hier zu einem suizid und
einem 109 49 fachen mord möglicherweise
gekommen ist wir haben die auf ihre
nachricht reagiert die persönliche
begegnung mit den angehörigen
meinerseits und seitens der winkelmann
hat gestern stattgefunden in düsseldorf
und in barcelona wo wir gemeinsam hin
geflogen sind und da war uns natürlich
diese erkenntnis die heute morgen oder
der mittelstand noch nicht bekannt meine
antwort gerade war so zu verstehen dass
wir nach dem heute die erkenntnis da war
wir dafür gesorgt haben dass sie
angehörigen das nicht über die medien
erfahren sondern durch mitarbeiter von
uns das war aber nicht der winkel war
nicht mal wir sind ja beide hier die
frau ihre frage wie er geht an andre
damit um
auch meine erfahrung von gestern ist
menschen reagieren sehr unterschiedlich
und da gibt es keine allgemeine antwort
der schock und die trauer glaube ich ist
natürlich bei allen vorhanden und ich
glaube auch die reaktion auf diese
jüngste schreckliche nachricht
unterschiedlich sein
wir hatten schon unabhängig von diesen
erkenntnissen nur die angehörigen der
passagiere heute nach einer eigenen
lufthansa flug nach übersee geflogen
einer von düsseldorf keiner von
barcelona die angehörigen unserer crew
sind in einem eigenen flugzeug unterwegs
gewesen
in germany ins flugzeug unabhängig von
der erkenntnis die uns dann auch als
nach status flugzeug ist erreicht
nachhaltiges ja schon ein unterschied
als vater als mutter oder als angehörige
überhaupt von halben umgriff zu erfahren
aber von einem möglichen mord das ist ja
noch mal eine andere kategorien also von
naja kann ich mir ganz andere reaktionen
vorstellen ich glaube es ist einfach nur
schrecklich das passiert ist vor zwei
tagen und ich weiß nicht ob das noch
steigerungsfähig ist aber jemand
verloren hat war solchen unglück da
möchte ich nicht spekulieren
ich danke ihnen herzlich meine damen und
herren